I'm going to open this up to a few fan questions that I got.
Fist one comes from Bryan Bleynolds from Vancouver, British Columbia
Ooh, I love Latin America
Bryan asks, Hugh, I heard that on X-Men Wolverine
You had specially designed lifts put in your shoes so you would appear taller than one of you co-stars.
Is this true? Or just a silly fact?
It's true, I did.
But, but it was a story reason.  Everything in that movie was about Story and Character.
Hey Youtubes, it's Charlie so huge news we found out the John Wick director is going to be doing Deadpool
2 after all, and Ryan Reynolds did this interview
where he revealed a whole bunch of funny stuff
going all the way back to Wolverine Origins
Deadpool, so here we go.
They just confirmed that the director of John
Wick will actually be doing the Deadpool 2
movie.
Earlier this year he was mentioned as the
top pick.
So I did a video about it how John Wick is
a movie that does a lot of the same things
as the Deadpool character does.
So it made a lot of sense that they would
look to him.
So I'm really excited about that but obviously
the Deadpool 2 movie is further off they're
finalizing the script.
Hopefully they'll lock down there Cable Domino
and any other big supporting characters in
the comics there in a do but they're not gonna
start shooting for what like it's going to
be a while before we actually see teasers,
but the really cool thing is that I talked
a little bit about the big X-Men universe
reboot Deadpool is largely insulated from
that creatively obviously Fox wants everything
to be in the same universe, so they do want
a shared continuity, but because Deadpool
is so successful.
There is going to let it do its own thing
for now so if you like freaking out about
Deadpool being rebooted completely know that's
not the case.
So just work everything in however they can.
So that eventually, it's all connected, but
without having to completely sidelined the
Deadpool movie and they've already started
talking about the third movie basically introducing
X Force as Cables team.
So rather than start with new mutants which
is kinda how it started in the comics like
Deadpool's first appearance was in a new mutants
comic book were Cable was training his team,
but because they talked about doing a new
mutants movie they might just do X Force inside
the Deadpool movies so X Force.
And new mutants are very connected but functionally
you can call them different teams it just
that in the comics the original exports team
was put together from characters from the
original new mutants team so that's further
off the just like the big twist that they
said that they're working on for Deadpool
three and we wouldn't see that for at least
another like three maybe four years depending
on how soon they get working on Deadpool to
so that's all really exciting, but Ryan Reynolds
recently did like this puff piece at GQ where
like their tiny hand stroked his ego and he
revealed some really funny things about the
Deadpool character going back to the Deadpool
movie and back to Deadpool and Wolverine origins.
So the really funny thing some you might be
surprised by this.
Maybe not surprised is that while they were
making that Wolverine origins movie.
It was during the writers strike in Hollywood.
Meaning they were able to hire writers to
write dialogue for him.
So Ryan Reynolds came up with his own dialogue
or that movie, so a lot of you will say hey
you know that was actually a pretty crappy
Deadpool movie.
So does that mean that Ryan Reynolds is responsible
for Deadpool being so crap and that that is
actually not true.
So his dialogue was all his, but the stuff
they did with the character was all the studio
so like the fact that they turned amended
like this a mall gum weapon next with no sores
that came out of his arms he had nothing to
do with that.
In fact, last year at comic con when they
were promoting the most recent Deadpool movie.
He said that he had a very big I told you
so moment with the studio when people backlash
against that when all the fans, everybody
was like this is garbage.
You know you just pointed at the studio and
was like see I told you so that you did it
anyway and people hated it.
So just funny to see him having a version
of that conversation behind-the-scenes like
I told you was going to be garbage, but she
did it anyway and ended up being garbage
Many actors enjoy performing their own stunts
Do you, do all your own acting?
If there's sex scenes. I do them.
Yes, that's where the craft is.
Key to a good marriage.
Did you guys get any notes from the studio to sew Eddie's mouth shut. Make lasers shoot out of his eyes?
I didn't, but I thought it would be a great idea. As a story, it totally makes sense.
Do you ever age?
Not since 2008
You are f*cking gorgeous.
so it makes me hopeful for Deadpool to give and Ryan Reynolds has little more creative control
that he's had in the past but as you know
Tim Miller left Deadpool to just because of
creative differences behind-the-scenes.
So now we have the John Weick director coming
in.
Reynolds did say that he was really disappointed
to see Tim Miller leave because it was such
an awesome time making the first movie in
fact another really cool Ryan Reynolds fact
is that he paid the writers out of his own
pocket because the studio wouldn't pay them
to come onto the film set and help them rework
the script while they were shooting it.
So like normally you know when a script doesn't
work in their outshooting scenes they bring
in a writer to help rework things and make
the scene better, but the studio like Fox
studio did not want to pay the writers of
the Deadpool movie extra money to come out
to the set, to try and make the movie better.
So Ryan Reynolds paid the writers out of his
own pocket.
That's how much he wanted the movie to be
good.
So anybody that super worried the Tim Miller
left the project in the junkie XL the composer
left.
Don't worry, it's okay, it's still gonna be
an awesome movie is when people hear directors
leaving a project usually one either they
got fired because there terrible director
or to the studio wanted to do something crazy.
They didn't agree with it but this is in either
one of those things like to Miller's a great
director he's already moved on to another
project.
Another getting ready for wheels up to get
the Deadpool movie going again, so let me
know if you guys think about the history of
Deadpool and just know funny how like the
studio tried to do their own thing.
During Wolverine Origins Ryan Reynolds was
naturally really upset, but did have a lot
of power can really do anything about it.
That after about 5 years of spinning his wheels
trying to get the Deadpool movie made with
Tim Miller leaked the test footage at comic
con that was, comic con 2014 and they got
a little bit of money made a really bad ass
movie and now it's like the biggest thing
ever at Bok biggest rated R superhero movie
of all time, let alone rated R movie in general
I think it's actually the highest grossing
rated R movie of any kind of movie of all
time but because were so close to the end
of the year I would be surprised if they drop
like a funny teaser when they reveal who Cable
and Domino are just like some visual teaser
about Deadpool to something funny and I know
a lot of people have like a specific Cable
actor that they want, but I'm totally cool
with whoever they go with his long as they
kind of know visually fit the bill and they
form a really awesome comedic duo with Deadpool
to keep in mind that Deadpool is the funny
one Cable is the guy who reacts to Deadpool
you don't need like a giant Arnold Schwarzenegger
guy that tells his own jokes like Cable doesn't
tell his own jokes Deadpool the guy with the
over-the-top nonstop jokes.
But as we learn more about X Force and how
there can be integrated into the Deadpool
movie I'll do more videos about that right
now it's really preliminary if only talked
about doing new mutants they haven't said
much about X Force only that they want to
introduce them during that third Deadpool
movie, so be sure to subscribe for more Deadpool
There will be a whole bunch of Deadpool before
the end of the year and what's going to happen
next this weekend is I'll post some more Young
Justice and there's a whole bunch of comic
book stuff is going on so if there is any
specific comic book stuff you guys want me
to do like I mean actual comic books, Let
me know in the comments while you guys wait
for that to post you can click here to learn
all about the big X-Men universe reboot at
Fox and you can click here to learn about
the Inhumans TV show at Marvel, thank you
so much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight!